[Music]
what if i told you that latin america
could have hosted one of the world's
greatest superpowers
capable of changing the course of
history in ways that only players like
the us china or russia can today
and to do that you'd only need to do one
thing
unite all of its countries into a single
state
how would this super nation turn into an
economic powerhouse
would it be a democracy or a
dictatorship
and why wouldn't other governments dare
mess with it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if latin america was a single
country
latin america is spread over both north
and south america with 19 sovereign
states and one independent territory
most of them considered developing
nations
there is some debate about what exactly
is latin america well for this scenario
we'll go with countries in the americas
where spanish and portuguese are
predominantly spoken
many people have had ambitions of
combining them to form a larger nation
the most famous of them being simone
bolivar known in south america as the
liberator
this venezuelan led the fight for
independence from spain across the
region and he believed uniting latin
america would be vital for its economic
and political success in the world
so what if bolivar did manage to build
one united nation
how could this super state turn into the
world's most feared dictatorship
the first step to accomplish this would
be to convince each nation's elites to
team up
with enough concessions deals and
compromises the wealthiest classes of
central and south america would have
been swayed to join their states
the liberator would have then been
appointed as the first president or
prime minister of this union and this
super state would be one of the largest
nations on the planet stretching from
the border with texas in the north to
tierra del fuego in the south
altogether it would include spanish and
portuguese south america the caribbean
central america and mexico
that's a total of more than 20 million
square kilometers
larger than the united states and canada
combined
and what a region it would be
the amazon rainforest in brazil coastal
waters and islands in puerto rico cuba
and the dominican republic the andes
mountain range that goes from chile all
the way up to colombia
glaciers in argentina tropical
grasslands in venezuela deserts in chile
these would be just a tiny fraction of
the multitude of landforms in the
supernation many of them rich with
natural resources and arable land
the potential for tourism year-round
agriculture and manufacturing would make
the rest of the world jealous
eight percent of humanity as well as
eight percent of its gdp would reside
within its borders that's around
660 million inhabitants in one of the
most diverse societies in the world
a nation with an astonishing abundance
of different peoples traditions and
cultures
everyone in this new united super nation
would speak either spanish or portuguese
all public documents would be printed in
both languages and schools would teach
students to have at least a basic
knowledge of the two
with this biodiversity of land and the
sheer size of its workforce this latin
america could become an economic
superpower just like the united states
and china
it would export everyday staples like
tobacco beef corn wheat fruits beans
vegetables sugar oh this list is long
most countries would be doing business
with this food production giant
brazil alone already leads the world in
coffee production harvests a quarter of
the global citrus has over one tenth of
all cattle supply and produces 12
percent of the sugarcane
it's already made it to the list of the
top 20 dominant economies on the planet
thanks to its massive iron and aluminum
ore reserves
as part of a bigger country where it
could share even more resources with
other territories brazil's economic
might would only be greater
imagine what it could do with venezuela
which has the planet's largest oil
reserves in its possession
naturally latin america would have its
own common currency
just like in the european union it would
make the region more attractive for
international business
so it seems like the latin american
super nation if successfully formed held
together and managed would fulfill
bolivar's dream of an astonishing
democratic superpower
right
well things are never quite that simple
latin america's abundance of natural
resources comes at the price of
widespread political and social unrest
you see the power would reside almost
solely with the wealthiest elite and as
time went on severe inequality would get
worse
an impoverished majority would be
socially politically and financially
marginalized by a small group of
oligarchs
class warfare would become inevitable
and with it the arrival of a prevalent
figure in latin american history the
caudillo also known as a strong man this
is a breed of military and political
leader with a big personality and a gift
for creating populist discourse fidel
castro in cuba and the gusto pinochet in
chile fit the ticket
extreme social division and discontent
would set the stage for the rise of one
of these strong men
they would speak for a silent majority
who in return would support their rise
to power
but once the caudillo took the reigns
they wouldn't want to let go
and they could turn democracy into a
dictatorship
but how would this strong man hold on to
one of the planet's superpowers
after all latin american countries
currently don't have the most advanced
or well-funded militaries
in 2016 their combined defense budget of
67 billion dollars was barely a drop in
the bucket compared to the
801 billion dollars of the united states
but on the other hand the region does
have a lot of soldiers almost 2 million
troops
so it looks like this super state
dictatorship wouldn't have the best
equipped military but it would be big
enough to control and suppress its
population and neutralize an uprising
but when it comes to dealing with
foreign enemies latin america would
require more drastic measures it could
side with russia a military powerhouse
and that would mean that latin america
would now have humanity's most
destructive weapon
nukes
this would change geopolitics worldwide
the united states would either have to
keep the peace or face having an enemy
at its gates
it would stay away from funding military
coups to remove anyone from power
it would just be too risky to do that to
a latin america armed with nukes
the influence of the west around the
world would be severely reduced
but despite this the united states would
still make out all right
with its vast mineral and energy
resources food exports and tourism
opportunities most american companies
would turn a blind eye to the human
rights abuses of the latin american
regime
so one of the planet's mightiest
superpowers would also be one of its
most solidified and accepted
dictatorships
you might want to reconsider where to
take your tropical vacation in this new
reality
as a single country latin america could
become a dangerous new threat to the
whole world
but what if
we united all the countries on the
planet
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you